should we play this video is it is it
really graphic uh there's one F-bomb I
will warn you I don't mind that just
letting everybody know you're showing
pictures or anything no no pictures no
all right just just a warning if you
have kids in the room or something
I was in the library and this book was
out of stand I'd like to read you a page
my back over my hips as I ask if we
should take off take our clothes off and
he's saying yes before I finish my
sentence he's pulling off my t-shirt
laughing when I can't undo his shirt
buttons he's undoing my belt I'm
reaching into his bedside drawer for a
condom we're kissing again we're rolling
over obviously you can see where this is
going I don't know if it's because we're
feeling especially emotional or just
tired or these past couple of weeks have
been too much but this reminds me so
much of the first time we had sex we
were both terrified and the
whole thing was kind of terrible I
didn't know what we were doing but it
was good too so good because we were a
mess of emotions and we were scared and
excited and everything felt new so this
sort of thing just sort of feels like
that Nick touches me like he's scared of
that in a minute
what book was that
Nick and Charlie it's like about it's
like two it's it's about gay people or
something
two teen board boys stealing wine from
their parents and proceeding to
experiment sexually with one another
guys he can't even say library properly
like why he should he be learning about
he says libraries I want to thank you
Knox for speaking up and out you got
courage man yeah nice job
that's that's a brutal to have to go
through that dude and I think the dad
said that this is actually not just at
the younger kids school he has an older
son who was at um a high school in the
area and said the book genderqueer is
allowed oh I have it yeah it's here yeah
sorry to interrupt you were saying no no
exactly but that's available in their
high school so it's clearly just that's
nuts because it's like putting a heavy
penises oh I mean I've seen the penises
but you gotta read it crazy that that
what he read man that that was not in
school when I was in school we had like
Newberry uh Amelia Bedelia and all this
stuff
yeah I wasn't in school that long ago
like I feel like how has it changed that
much it would have been a huge deal if
someone found that book in my school oh
yeah everyone would have known about it
it would have been all our parents I
would have told her my parents everybody
would have known about it it would have
been a just uh people would have lost
their jobs for this kind of thing in
1987. the genderqueer book I think most
people watching the show already know
what I've had to say about it but
conservatives haven't even read it and
every time I talk to some conservatives
like oh yeah I know that book I'm like
did you read it the answer is no and
then my attitude is like
this is why I am not in favor of blanket
book bands because people should be able
to have access to something to
understand what it is
that's totally different than if
children are getting access to something
I think certain you know information
like certain books and stuff should be
restricted for children obviously we ban
porn but this book is the story of the
extreme psychological abuse of a young
woman and how it created someone who is
traumatized and needs like deep therapy
it is not this it is not so uh for a few
examples for those who didn't hear this
she couldn't read till she was 12. she
was pissing outside when she was a child
she was never taught how to take care of
her body so she would wear old crusted
pads in school and she smelled like
feces to the point where she got called
into the counselor and they complained
and said people are complaining of your
smell and you need to do something about
this so this poor young woman Harry lags
hairy armpits
totally unsocialized by weird hippie
parents whoever ping in the yard and
then she she feels she feels some kind
of social rejection because she doesn't
know how to fit in with her peers and
she writes about it how she's like I
can't read I smell bad and people are
being mean to me so so she she she's not
she's not non-binary she's just
traumatized because she was not because
her parents abused her and this this
thing book that Knox is reading I still
know Nick and Charlie uh about two young
underage kids drinking alcohol like is
that a form of neglect abuse by the
parents the kid not that you can't like
a kid's gonna do what a kid does but I
believe if you parent the kid properly
like I didn't drink until I was 23
because my parents told me don't do it
it's horrible for you I tasted it once
it tasted disgusting I was like all
right I'm not gonna do it I think you
might be in the minority on that yeah
that's kind of weird I gotta say it's
kind of weird that um this Nick and
Charlie book's written by a woman
I just think that's weird maybe that's
just me
like if it was written by
a gay man writing about his experience
growing up and discovering he was gay
and stuff I'd be like I get it but it's
written by a woman who is like it almost
seems like some kind of weird
I don't know she's sitting there
imagining what it must be like to be a
teenage boy hooking up with another
teenage boy you just it's just doesn't
you think that their mentality because
this should not be in a school a book
about two young underage kids having sex
with each other should not be in a
government School in my opinion but you
think the argument's like hey there's so
many books anyway we can't keep count
and it's all on the internet anyway if
they want to read it it's there I've
heard that argument a lot of times like
if kids want to get access to the stuff
they're going to get access to it so we
might as well have it be like the uh you
know Pulitzer prize-winning version of
it access to information because of the
internet is a big issue I think when an
age where kids could get on the internet
could be a big issue because if they
could access the internet they could get
crazier stuff than anything that's
written in this book absolutely I don't
know what about tick tocks the woman who
wrote this is like 28 or 29 years old
yeah so we see videos from lives of tick
tock of crazier stuff people are going
to drag queen story hours and there have
been some crazy videos that they
uploaded recently of some things in
England where they're like tripping in
front of children
I'm not even exaggerating it's like a
dozen babies all crawling on the ground
and they're like remember when you saw
that for like the Teletubbies when you
were like oh my gosh the Teletubbies and
now it's like oh my gosh a stripper for
babies I think that's Teletubbies were
grooming kids because that was after my
kid time I was out of the house I just
thought they were so weird and
brainwashy like
after and like making this weird beeping
sounds and like gyrating back and I'm
like what is this God it was weird I
don't know I was mesmerized the scariest
thing was no it was the Flaming baby
head burning baby head that would be in
the sky going ah and you're like no
Teletubbies was fine I don't know I just
don't understand why I do all this weird
stuff for kids where it's like think
about the pre-television era what were
children seeing all day every day in
their entertainment a human being
telling a story reading a book with very
few pictures and then when TV comes
around all of a sudden you got like
Snuffleupagus and like big bird and
weird creepy monster things going like
oh roll and the kids are like I identify
with that
there was a time that's how we got
furries um yes
parents put kids in front of TVs and
turn on Looney Tunes and then these kids
start identifying with the social
interactions of cartoon animals and
that's why when you look at pictures of
furries they don't dress up like actual
animals they dress up like Bugs Bunny
kind of animals with big eyes and they
look like cartoon characters one of the
anime culture too though furry yeah I
don't know about that oh my gosh yeah
these I mean we were just at um katsukan
um my team and I well I didn't go but my
team went and we were all discussing
everything
um it's fascinating to see the anime
culture and a the road in inroads it has
into grooming actually what is katsukan
I'm sorry
anime lover nerdy people it's it's I it
felt very harmless when I was there
until I learned how the inroads of it I
mean that that can take you from
something very harmless like dressing up
like a furry or dressing up like an
animal furry is not cosplay
yes and yes and no some of them have
those conventions just like that I mean
they're not the same thing furry is very
different from cosplay but there's
probably some overlap for sure yeah some
furries cosplay some don't yeah there
was a cosplaying furry at my high school
yeah I mean there's there's for some
reason furry Nazis like they wear ferk
suits and they get like they dress up
like whatever man I don't know I was
fortunate to grow up in the era of
Reading Rainbow with LeVar Burton what's
up Levar one of the best I mean just
easy shows where he just reads a book or
actually a kid would read the book and
then Mr Rogers where it's a guy a
genuine dude like sitting there looking
at the camera giving you encouragement
and then educating You by reading your
books and telling you about it's how to
tie your shoes and like things you know
like things that kids may not know
I thought I thought that like I was
thinking this and I couldn't type it out
it wasn't it wasn't it's not a typable
thing but like until you're able as a
human to create order in in reality
around you I don't think you should have
the ability to cut yourself up or or
sterilize yourself and like I just
assumed every kid eventually will get to
a place where they can create order in
reality I don't think that's the case
though you need a good strong parental
unit to help you learn how to do that I
think we're seeing how broken culture
and Society is because of the the us
being cut from our roots you know what
was it cut flower politics or whatever
that uh Dennis Prager calls it you pluck
the flower from its roots and it looks
beautiful but then eventually Withers
and decays and so we've been severed
from the roots that have made this
country an amazing place and so now
we're starting to wither you know I
would like to do a Tim cash show if you
want to do a show where I read books to
kids and talk to them and encourage them
I think that's we need more of that it
doesn't have to be the kids either I
actually have I did the Phantom toll
booth I have like a 19 video series on
YouTube on my playlists where I read the
Phantom toll booth it's one of my most
popular it's my most popular playlist by
far no we should do a go-go dancer Story
Hour yeah we need more some like just
genuine encouragement for children the
left would love it you'd make tons of
money
well they they they're totally into that
stuff right that's a money maker right
there go go dancer Story Hour there's no
difference there's literally none go go
dancers do not get naked they dance on
stage they start around for tips and
they remove parts of clothing but they
still keep their undergarments is it
just too like is it just have we evolved
past showing kids puppets and telling
them you're okay and and being cool is
that just no more no give it up like
forget about it move on I
actually just goes to my point that I
made earlier which is like the go-go
dancers would somehow be dubbed
inappropriate because you're sexualizing
women because it's a straight thing but
you know you get into you make it LGBT
male go-go dancers and
I don't even know you're not explaining
only if the males kiss each other
Magic Mike kisses there you go yeah then
it's not really in a pro then it's
considered appropriate like I don't even
want to wait wait I don't even want to
read other people two lady go go dancers
but they kissed before
then it would be appropriate it sounds
like like the society the reaction I
just got from mentioning talking reading
to kids is like it's like this don't
mess with other people's kids like I
don't even want to get involved now I
don't even want to touch it like let
those kids do it on their own I don't
want to have something who said that the
whole the whole vibe is like it's just
so dirty about like Ian's feelings got
hurt because nobody supported it I don't
know man why are people not more
interested in helping children I don't
they would talk about the problems all
day no but where's the solutions thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time